we started out going very broad and
looking at lots of different solutions
out there not necessarily just for
trauma but across the spectrum to
address different symptoms of
Parkinson's disease and this is actually
really part of this whole design
thinking methodology which is to look at
analogous experiences so taking your
poor problem and then looking at
adjacent spaces where there might be
solutions in a completely different area
that can inform upon the challenge that
you're tackling you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
hi Anne Jung is a designer technologist
and maker of things really cool
technical things who currently holds the
unusual title of innovation director at
the Microsoft research lab in Cambridge
England there she applies her unusual
skillset to a wide range of unusual
solutions to real-life problems many of
which draw on novel applications of
gaming technology in serious areas like
healthcare on today's podcast Haiyan
talks about her unique brain hack
approach to the human centered design
process and discusses a wide range of
projects from the connected play
experience of Zanzibar to physio which
turns laborious breathing exercises for
children with cystic fibrosis into a
video game to project Emma an
application of haptic vibration
technology that somewhat curiously
offsets the effects of tremors caused by
Parkinson's disease that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast hi I'm John welcome to
the podcast
hi thanks Gretchen great to be here you
are the innovation director at MSR
Cambridge in England which is a super
interesting title what is an innovation
director what does an innovation
director do what gets an innovation
director up in the morning I guess it is
quite an unusual title it's a kind of a
bespoke role I would say because of my
quite unusual background I guess part of
what I do is look at how technology can
be applied in real use cases in the
world to create business impact within
Microsoft and outside of Microsoft and
to make those connections between our
deeply technical research with applied
product groups across the company so is
this a job that existed at MSR in
Cambridge or did you arrive with this
unique set of talents and skills and
background and ability and bring the job
with you I would say it's something that
I brought with me and it's evolving over
time
well unpack that a little bit how has it
evolved since you began when did you
begin so I actually joined Microsoft
about five and a half years ago and
actually initially joined as part of the
Xbox organization running an innovation
team in Xbox in London and looking at
new play experiences for kids for teens
that were completely outside of the box
and then from that I transitioned into
Microsoft research and part of my team
also continued on that research in terms
of creating completely new technology
experiences around entertainment and
more recently I'm working across the lab
with various projects to see how we can
connect our sort of fundamental computer
science work better with products across
Microsoft in terms of as a cloud
infrastructure in terms of Xbox and
gaming in terms of office and
productivity you've been in high tech
for nearly 20 years and you've worked in
engineering and user experience and
research Rd hardware service design etc
and even out in the blue sky envisioning
space so that brings a lot to the party
in the form of one person quite frankly
I'm impressed how has your experience in
each or all of these areas informed how
you approach the research you do today
well thanks really I'm quite honored to
be on the podcast actually because I'm
so impressed with all the researchers
that you've been interviewing across all
the MSL labs so I would say that in the
research work that I do I bring a very
human centered lens to looking at
technology so I undertake a full human
centered design process starting from
talking to people gaining empathy with
people trying to extract insight from
what people really need and then going
deeply into the technical research to
develop prototypes technology ideas to
support those needs and then deploying
those
prototypes in the field to understand
how that can be improved and how we can
evolve our technology thinking let's
talk about design thinking then for a
minute I don't know if you'd call it
discrete from computational thinking or
any other kind of thinking but it seems
to be a buzz phrase right now so as a
self-described designer technologist and
maker of things how would you define
design thinking so I would say that
design thinking is not separate from
computational thinking it's a layer
above it's just an approach to problem
solving and it's basically a toolkit
that allows you to utilize different
methods to really gain an understanding
of people's needs to gain an
understanding of insight into how
people's lives can be improved through
technology and then tools around
prototyping and evaluating those
prototypes so I would say that it is not
in itself a scientific method but it can
be used to improve and augment your
existing practice let's get specific now
and talk about some of those projects
that you've been working on starting
with project Zanzibar what was the
inspiration behind this project how did
you bring it to life and how does it
embody your idea of connected play
experiences that you've talked about I
think there is a rich history in
computer science of tangible user
interfaces you know some of the early
work at Xerox PARC even or at the MIT
Media Lab around how we can create these
seamless interactions between people
between their physical environments and
between a digital universe hmm and I
think the approach we had to Zanzibar
was that the most fruitful area for
exploration intangible user interfaces
would be to enable kids to play and
learn through physicality through
interacting with physical objects that
were augmented
with virtual information because we're
really trying to tap into this idea of
multimodal learning and learning through
play so just coming from this initial
approach we dive very deeply into how
would we invent completely new
technology platform to enable people to
very seamlessly manipulate objects in a
natural way using gestures and then
bring about some new digital experiences
layered on top of that that were games
or education scenarios and in sort of
bringing those together in terms of
really fundamental technology invention
but also applications that could
demonstrate what that technology could
be right well and it's too bad that this
is an audio-only experience here on the
podcast because there's a really cool
overview of this project on the
Microsoft Research website and it's a
very visual artifact based approach to
playing with computers yeah yeah and I
encourage everyone to visit the project
page and take a look at some of the
videos and our prototypes that we have
published right so what was the thinking
behind tying in the artifact and the
digital you know there's this rich
history of research with physical
objects and we've proven out that
physical digital interaction is a great
way forward in terms of novel
interactions between people and
computing but the pragmatics of these
systems have not been ideal you know if
you have to be sat at your desk and
there has to be an overhead camera yeah
usually a lot of research projects
involve this or there's occlusion in
terms of where your hand can be and
where the physical objects can be
because the cameras won't be able to
track it so what we set out to do was
think about well how would you design a
technology platform that overcomes a lot
of these barriers to these platforms so
that we can then be freed up to think
about those scenarios but we can also
empower
other researchers who are doing research
in the space to think about those
scenarios so our research group we had
this idea of leveraging NFC but
leveraging it in terms of an NFC antenna
array so that we could track objects in
a 2d space hmm and then the additional
novelty was also layering that with a
capacitive multi-touch layer so that we
could track both the objects in terms of
the physical IDs of the objects on top
of the surface area the capacitive
multi-touch would enhance that tracking
that the NFC provided but also we could
track hand gestures both in terms of
multi-touch gestures on top of the
surface and also some hover gestures
just above the surface as well
[Music]
let's talk a bit about another really
cool project that you're working on
I know Cambridge your lab is deeply and
maybe even uniquely invested in
researching and developing technologies
to improve healthcare and you have a
couple projects going on in this area
one of them project physio I'll smell it
it's f as in Frank I Zizi why Oh tell us
about this project how did it come about
what's the technology behind it and how
does it work
so physio really started as a
collaboration with the BBC and we were
inspired by one family the mum Vicky she
has four kids and two of her boys have
cystic fibrosis they have a genetic
condition where their internal organs
are constantly secreting mucus and so
every day twice a day the boys have to
do this laborious breathing exercise to
expel the mucus from their lungs and it
involves breathing into these plastic
apparatus and they basically apply
pressure to your breath so that when you
breathe it creates an oscillating effect
in your lungs and escalates the mucus
and then it culminates and you coughing
and trying to cough out the mucus from
your lungs they're usually plastic
devices where as you blow the air kind
of enters a chamber and there might be
some sort of mechanism that oscillates
the air like a ball-bearing that bounces
up and down and so they're very low fie
so there's no digital aspect to these
devices right and you can imagine these
kids they're having to do these
exercises from a very early age from as
early as they can remember twice a day
for 30 minutes for an hour at a time
it's really intensive and it can be if
not painful at least really
uncomfortable to do and I actually tried
to do this once and I felt really
lightheaded I actually couldn't do one
session of it and also the kids they
want to be outside playing with their
friends you know they don't want to be
stuck in billa's doing this all the time
and there is no
thread from doing the exercise and
feeling and improvement because the
activity is about maintenance so you're
trying to maintain your health because
if you don't clear the mucus from your
lungs infection can set in and that
means going to the hospital that means
getting antibiotics and so it's a very
challenging thing for Vicki their mom to
be jostling them be harassing them to do
this all the time and she said that her
role has really changed with their kids
that she's no longer a mum she's sort of
nagging them all the time hmm and so we
visited with the family to really
understand their play and she asked you
know can we create a piece of technology
that can help us in getting the kids to
do this kind of physio treatment is a
type of physio and so we actually came
up with this idea together where he said
you know the boys really love to play
video games so what if we could create a
way for the boys to be playing a video
game as they are undertaking this
exercise so we started this process of
prototyping and developing a digital
attachment a sensor that attaches to all
these various different physio devices
and as the patient is expelling is
breathing out the sensor actually senses
the breath and transmits that digital
signal to a tablet and we can translate
that signal into controls for a video
game and we're also able to upload that
to the cloud to do further analysis on
that medical treatment Wow
how's it working we started this project
about two and a half years ago it's been
a long process but it's really fruitful
and rewarding one so we started out with
just some early prototypes just using
off-the-shelf electronics to get the
breath sensor working just right we
added a single button because we
realized if you were just using the
breath to play video games it's actually
really challenging and then within the
team our industrial designer Greg Saul
design
find the physical attachment we
developed our own sensor board and we
had it manufactured along with the
product design and we partnered with
University College London their
physiotherapy department and the Great
Ormond Street Hospital in London where
they've deployed over a hundred of these
units with kids across the country to do
a long term trial so actually when we
first met with the University College
London physiotherapy department I mean
this is the department that they've
spent their entire careers working with
kids in this domain and they had never
had any contact with the computer
science department this was not a
digital research area when they first
met us and they saw on the computer
screen someone breathing out and a graph
showing that breath the peak of that
breath one of the heads of department
that we were working with she started to
cry because she said that in her entire
career she had never seen physio data
visualized in this way it was just
incredible for her Wow and so we decided
to partner and they've been amazing
because through this journey they've
gone to meet people in the computer
science department they initiated
master's degrees incorporating data
science and digital understanding they
just hired their first data scientists
in order to leverage the platform that
we've built to do further analysis to
improve the health of these kids and
they said that even though this kind of
exercise has been around for decades
no-one has actually done a definitive
long-term study to track the efficacy of
this kind of exercise to health to
outcomes you know because I think past
studies have really relied on keeping
paper Diaries answering questionnaires
mmm but no one's done that digital study
which is what the power of Internet of
Things can really bring you which is
tracking in the background in a very
precise way talk about the role of
machine learning how do any of the new
methodologies in computer science like
machine learning methods and techniques
play into this you know what's really
interesting with machine learning is the
availability of data and you know we
understand that what's driven this AI
revolution is now the availability of
large data sets to actually be able to
develop new ml algorithms and models and
in many cases especially in healthcare
there is the lack of data so I think
throughout different areas of computer
science research there's a real need to
kind of connect the dots and actually
develop IOT solutions that can start at
the beginning and capture the data
because it's only through cleverly
capturing valid data that we can then do
the machine learning in the backend mmm
once we've done the data collection and
so I think the physio project is a
really good proof point of that in that
we started out with IOT in order to
gather the information that track the
health exercises and we've just sort of
deployed in the UK so as we're
collecting this data we're now able to
look at that and start to do some
predictions around long-term health so
you know some of the questions that the
physiotherapy researchers are trying to
answer is if kids are very adherent to
this kind of exercise if they're doing
what they're being told they're doing
this twice a day for the duration that
they're supposed to be doing it and does
that mean in six months time or a year's
time their number of days in hospital is
going to be reduced does it actually
impact how much time they're spending
being ill if we see a trailing off of
this exercise does that mean that we'll
see an increase in infection rates so
with the data that we're collecting
we're now working with the
different part of Microsoft they called
the Microsoft commercial software
engineering team who are actively
delving into projects around AI for good
and they're going to be working with UCL
to do some of this clustering and
developing models around health
predictions so clustering the patients
into different cohorts to understand if
there is prediction factors around how
they're doing the exercises and how much
time they're going to be spending in
hospital in the years to come
well it almost would be hard for me to
get more excited about something than
what you've just described in project
physio but there is another project to
talk about which is project Emma this is
so cool it's even been featured on a
documentary series there in the UK
called the big life fix and it didn't
just start with a specific idea but with
a specific person tell us the story of
Emma yes so again project Emma started
with a single person with Emma Lawton
who when she was 28 years old she was
diagnosed with early onset Parkinson's
disease and it had been five years since
her diagnosis and some of her symptoms
had progressed quite quickly and one of
them was an active tremor so her trauma
would get worse as she started to write
or draw and this really affected how she
went about her day-to-day work because
she was a creative director a graphic
designer
and day to day she would be in client
meetings talking with people and trying
to sketch out what they meant in terms
of the ideas that they had and she would
not be able to do that and when I first
met with her she would sit with a
colleague and her colleague would
actually draw on her behalf so she
really was looking for some kind of
technology intervention to help her and
we started out going very broad and
looking at lots of different solutions
out there not necessary
only just for trauma but across the
spectrum to address different symptoms
of Parkinson's disease and this is
actually really part of this whole
design thinking methodology which is to
look at analogous experiences so taking
your core problem and then looking at a
jacent spaces where there might be
solutions in a completely different area
that can inform upon the challenge that
you're tackling so we looked at lots of
different solutions for other kinds of
symptoms and of course there was a lot
of desk research it was reading research
papers that had been published over the
decades that looked at tremor
specifically so I think the two aspects
that really influenced our thinking one
was around going to visit with a local
charity called Parkinson's UK and we
were asking them to show us their
catalogue of widgets and devices that
they sold to Parkinson's patients that
helped them in their everyday and on the
table there was a digital metronome so
you know when you were playing the piano
you see musicians they have this ticking
metronome and I asked you know so why is
there a metronome on the table and the
lady said well for some Parkinson's
patients they have a symptom called
freezing of gait and this is where when
you're walking along your legs suddenly
freeze and you lose control of your legs
and so sometimes people find that if
they take out this metronome and they
turn it on and it makes this rhythmic
ticking sound it's somehow distracts
their brain into being able to walk
again
which is really kind of odd there's been
a little bit of literature around this
in the literature is called cueing it's
a cueing effect but it doesn't apply to
tremor but for me it sort of signaled an
interesting brain Hat and signaled kind
of underlying what might be going on in
your brain when you have Parkinson's
disease at the same time there have been
a number of papers around using
vibration on the muscles to try to
you're a trauma to try to address it to
various affect and not specifically
looking at Parkinson's but looking at
other kinds of trauma diseases like a
central tremor dystonia and so we
developed a hypothesis and in order to
test out the hypothesis we developed a
prototype which was a wearable device
for the wrist that had a number of
vibrating motors on it so would apply
vibration to the wrist in a rhythmic
fashion in order to somehow circumvent
the mechanism that was causing the
tremor and of course we had a number of
other hypotheses too this was not the
only hypotenuse we had other devices
that worked in a completely different
way that was more about mechanically
stopping the tremor mechanically
countering the tremor and this device
actually worked really well so we were
surprised but very very happy and so
this is the direction that we took in
order to further develop this product
right so drilling in I do want to
mention that there's a video on this on
the website as well it's a video that
made me cry I think it made you cry
anime Democrats were all just puddles of
Tears because it's so fantastic and so
this kind of circles back to research
writ large and experimenting with ideas
that may not necessarily be super what
we would call high tech maybe they're
kind of low Phi you know a vibration
tool that can keep you from shaking so
how did it play out how did you
prototype this give us a little overview
of your process for us it was a very
simple prototyping exercise we took some
off-the-shelf coin cell motors and
developed basically a haptic type
bracelet that we then had an app that
you could program the haptics on the
bracelet and that's what we sort of
experimented with so just research from
the haptics area of computer science
research was really about a mechanism
for sensing something about the digital
world now applied to this medical
domain
[Music]
you have a diverse slate of projects
going on at any given time and your
teams are really diverse so I want you
to talk specifically about the
composition of skills and expertise that
are required to bring some of these
really fascinating research projects to
life and ultimately to market who's on
your team and what do they bring to the
party well I think this is something
really unique about Microsoft research
and Microsoft Research Cambridge in
particular we have such a broad
portfolio of projects but also expertise
in the different computer science fields
that we can sort of pull together these
multidisciplinary teams to go after a
single topic so within our lab we have
social scientists doing user research
gaining real insight into how people
behave how people think about various
technologies we have designers that are
exploring user interfaces exploring
products to bring these ideas to life we
have you know computer vision specialist
we have machine learning specialists we
have natural language processing people
systems researchers and securities
researchers and obviously healthcare
researchers so it's that broad outlook
that I think can really push forward in
terms of technology innovation and
really emphasizing the applications for
people for improving society as a whole
I ask all my guests some form of the
question is there anything that keeps
you up at night and I know that many
people namely parents are worried that
their kids are to engage with screens
are not spending enough time in real
life and so on what would you say to
them and is there anything that keeps
you up at night about sort of the
broader swath of what you're working on
you know on the topic of screen time
obviously it's something that we really
wrestled with zanzabar research
specifically which is thinking about how
you could interact with physical objects
instead of a digital
and also bringing that kind of bigger
interaction surface between family and
between friends they could interact
together you know at the same time I
would say that culture is constantly
changing and how we live our lives is
constantly changing we've only seen the
Internet be really embedded in our lives
in the last I'd say 20 years 15 years 20
years when I think we were younger we
had television and there were no
computers and so I say culture is
constantly evolving how we're growing
how we're living is constantly evolving
it's important for parents to evaluate
this changing landscape of Technology
and to figure out what is the best thing
to do with their kids and maybe you
don't have to rely on how you grew up
but to kind of evaluate that our kids
are getting the right kind of social
interaction getting the right amount of
parental support and quality time with
their family I think that's what's
important but except that how we're
growing is changing what about the idea
of the Internet of Things and privacy
when we're talking about toys and kids
yeah is something we really have to
watch out for and you know we've seen
some bad examples of the toy industry
jumping ahead too far and enabling toys
to be connected 24/7 and conversing with
kids and what does that really mean I've
seen some really great research out of
the MIT Media Lab where there was a
researcher really looking at how kids
are conversing with AI with different AI
agents and their mental model of these
AI agents so I think that's a really
great piece of research to look at but
also maybe to expand upon as research
community if we're thinking about kids
to understand that how kids are
interacting with AI is going to be more
commonplace and rather than trying to
avoid it to really tackle it head-on and
see how we can improve the principles
designing AI how we can inform companies
and the market out there of what is the
ethical approach to doing this so that
kids really understand what AI is as
they're growing up with it we're coming
up on an event at Microsoft Research
called I chose stem and it's all about
encouraging women to well choose stem as
an area of study or a career yeah so
tell us the story of how you chose it
what got you interested in a career in
high tech in general and maybe even high
tech research specifically who are your
influences I have a I guess slightly
unique background and that I was born in
China and at the time it was very kind
of communist education that I had when I
was growing up and my family moved to
Australia when I was 8 years old and I
was always very technical and very nerdy
but I never thought about technology as
a career I actually wanted to study law
and computing was just something where I
was sort of you know it was kind of fun
but I never thought about it as a career
and I say in the last sort of year of
high school I decided to switch and do
computer science and I realized that I
was actually really good
I guess what led me to choose stem is
just the I think the fun and creativity
you can have with programming you know I
would always come up with my own little
creative exercises to write on the
computer
it wasn't the rote exercises it was the
ability to kind of be creative with this
technical tool that really got me
excited I think at the same time I love
this huge effort within our industry to
really focus on getting more women more
girls into technology into STEM
education and you know we really want to
increase representation increase sort of
equal representation at the same time I
think I found it at times to be you know
challenging to be the only woman in the
room you know when I was in computer
science sometimes I'd be you know one of
three women in the lecture theatre or
something hmm I think we need to adopt
this kind of pioneer mindset
so that we can go into these new areas
go into a room where you're the only
person where you're unique in that room
and you have something to contribute and
don't be afraid to speak up
I think that's a really important
mindset and skill for anybody to have no
interview would be complete if I didn't
ask my guests to predict the future no
pressure I am seriously though you are
living on the cutting edge of technology
research which is what this podcast is
all about and so what advice or
encouragement you've just kind of given
some would you give to any of our
listeners across the board who might be
interested or inspired by what you're
doing who's a good fit for the research
you do my advice would be especially in
the research domain to develop that deep
research expertise but to keep a
holistic outlook I think the research
landscape is changing in that we are
going to be working in more
multidisciplinary teams working across
departments you know sometimes it's the
healthcare department the physiotherapy
department with the computer science
department it's through the connection
of these disparate fields that I think
we're going to see dramatic impact from
technology and I think for researchers
to have that holistic outlook to visit
other departments to understand what are
the challenges beyond their own group I
think is really really important and
develop collaboration skills and
techniques hi Ann Jung it's been a
delight thanks for joining us today
thanks so much Gretchen it's been a real
pleasure thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about high-end young and
other scientists who are pushing the
boundaries of technology to transform
human lives visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]